[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ich
hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut heute
endlich zu challenge die ich ja letzten
mal schon angekündigt habe und zwar
brauchen wir dafür nicht aufmachen alice
ich mitbekommen haben ich habe mir
letztens zu einem eigenen automaten im
bestellt oder nicht bestellt haben
gekauft macht mal ganz normales videos
einkaufen nach malta wocheneinkauf setzt
[Musik]
ja für das heutige video bin ich nicht
alleine ich habe vier gäste und wir
spielen gleich um was wirklich krass ist
und zwar um ein iphone ein echtes iphone
7 es ist kein iphone ist es trotzdem gut
ist einfach nicht mein ding kostet neu
auch bestimmt 6 700 euro oder mehr
500 deswegen verzeichnete die vierfache
werbung auf diesem weg was also ich
würde sagen ihr könnt alle mal kurz vor
die kamera treten
nein ich bin cedrick ich bin also
eigentlich bin der meinung dass
eigentlich mein youtube namen
konnte sagt sebastian was ich die chance
weitere was ist
wir wollen gar nicht eingeladen und ich
würde sagen ich erkläre ich mal ganz
kurz die spielregeln und zwar wie hier
das ei phone 7 ist das aufgeladen wollte
manchmal kurzstrecken also ein kleines
iphone kein iphone 7 plus was auch immer
es da geb ich kenne mich da nicht aus
das tun wir uns leichter rein und man
kann sich ja denken worum es geht wir
spielen dann immer hintereinander wir
stellen uns allen so eine reihe wie
früher im kindergarten und dann ist
immer der nächste dran und darf die
greift automatisch und darf den greifarm
halt runterfahren und dann an das handy
zu kommen das ist schwieriger als man
denkt also ich glaube das dauert
wirklich und man muss wirklich mit
fingerspitzengefühl da an die sache ran
gehen weil sonst wird das nichts
und ich bin auch wirklich mal gespannt
wie schnell wir das schaffen hallo also
also iphone kommen die rein und ab in
den automaten
so deute die schlange stellen mitte bist
du bereit mich zweifel hatte ich bin
erst dann will ich dritter seien nicht
angesagt und bitte die handys im flug
deswegen stößt das hast du mit dem
automat immer ich es ist ja auch die
medcup wurde daraus teil der game master
war schickten stunden später fanden
offenbar schnell repariert und jetzt ist
es heute möglich verträge aufgehoben
euro nachhaltig gesehen mache ich war
ganz schlecht ist am besten passen hier
hast du auch in thailand
ja ich hab ja noch 14 bis jetzt nicht
vertreten das hat das ist also das
müsste zu gehen na ja geht wo ist ja
nicht mal muss jetzt mal ein bisschen
schneller hier sonst so dass er ewig das
nicht so gut dass wir uns überraschen
lassen daumen hoch da es auch spannend
findet es gut
also braucht es war das video spannend
machen wir das nicht sollte man darf so
nicht erschrecken weg durch das noch
immer
[Musik]
kriegt das ding mit längst das gar nicht
mal schlecht doch wo aber war der beste
versuch vereine das heißt du versuchst
du immer das beste für sie war mein
erster ganz knapp
welcher mensch du hast deine eigenen
traumhaus
[Applaus]
die den reporter zwischen und das kann
man für das an das geld und das war gut
für uns
das geklappt
ich bin das iphone 4 1 durch
nächstes mal geben wir danken ganz
mittig ist vielleicht manchmal kannst du
schlägt im jahr wie man die krippen
wurde ein bisschen weiter rauchen was
ist das man kann keinen physikalisch
kann man das ganze gehen wir dafür die
studie
also das ist natürlich da aber nicht
dass jetzt gewinne dann dax behalten so
hoch der ist gut man spaß das geht
entweder mit mir fehlte sachen oder
neubau der ist auch der ist verdammt gut
und er ist gut doch so beschissen ja das
wird jetzt pech gehabt
leute übrigens bei 10.000 sagt oder mit
anderen teilnehmern und zwar etwas
wirklich cool ist reingelegt da bin ich
auch mal gespannt ob das pflanzen also
wenn ihr darauf gehabt dann beschreibt
es gerne in den kommentaren mit hashtag
automaten geld ja richtig 0 uhr ist
jetzt erst mal einer stunde war nicht
gut aus automatischen die zigarette wir
sind privat bei den kumpels zu hause das
team gekauft
ja ich weiß hört sich geladen
er sieht gut aus china waren das ist ja
schon
hallo es ist schneller machen die kamera
hält auch nicht bis zum überholen
ja okay leute ich will mich jetzt ganz
kurz zeigen wie man das ganze markt und
da haben wir ganz gegessen und er ist
gut und das streaming greifbar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mann mann mann mann mann mann mann mann
mann zu rechnen
das war nicht verstecken ich glaube
jetzt sieht das nämlich jetzt hier
schreibe ttc altena keiner glaubt dann
martina t
aber jetzt jetzt haben wir auf jeden
fall eine richtig gute position weil es
schön runter geht elisabeth ersten video
und erst recht unmöglich leute nein es
ist nicht unmöglich dass gut dass sich
schrittweise dem zirkel um die who dazu
nicht sagen
sie sind
[Applaus]
jetzt mal zu haben
was meint ihr oder jemand so etwas war
es jetzt für eine perfekte packers wales
will den festwirten ins auge
okay das video heißt automat extrem also
darf man auch jetzt den automatischen
beliebig schütteln wie man will
sie reden würde ich raten wenn er kaputt
machen somit sei also jetzt muss es eine
kriegen sonst ist vielleicht die kamera
sehr schlecht aus einem server alles ist
aber nicht alles durchgehen und china
produziert
nein
so
wenn es was ich habs nur die johann die
nachbarn wir haben schon recht spät aber
du hast du ihn beste was der bund daher
können wir auch endlich wieder gehen
leute das auch mit dem video es war
wirklich sehr chaotisch aber es hat spaß
gemacht wenn ihr sagt macht und weil
noch nur 2 halo auf mich die ganze
gemobbt die ganze zeit ist also
herzlichen glückwunsch
die frau geworden viel spaß damit
danke checkt auf jeden fall die ganzen
kanälen sind alle in der video scheidung
verhängt sind echte super leute hier mit
am start
gute videos sowie matthias und erhalten
für zwei ein paar nach oben das war sein
danke dass du dabei sein dürfen